-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You are here! You made it!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for watching!
Let's get to some news.
Well, guys, the White House just
backed a bipartisan Senate bill
that would give President Biden
the power to ban TikTok.
-Ooh.
[ Audience "oohs" ]
Or, as they're calling it
on TikTok,
the "Trying to Lose
the Election Challenge."
[ Laughter ]
I wouldn't worry just yet.
As of now, Biden thinks TikTok
is the clock on "60 Minutes."
So it's...
[ Laughter ]
Don't worry. To make it up,
Biden promised us
that he'd give everybody
100 free hours of AOL.
So that's good.
[ Laughs ]
[ Applause ]
[ Cymbals crash ]
Yeah, officials think China
is using TikTok to spy on us.
Then China was like, "Yeah,
well, we had a backup idea,
but you shot it down, so...
how are we supposed to --
how are we...?"
That's right.
There's a new Senate bill
that would allow Biden
to ban TikTok.
It's obviously
a very controversial bill,
and a lot of politicians
are speaking out about it.
For example,
Senator James Lankford said...
[ Laughter ]
Then Senator Rick Scott said...
And Senator Chuck Grassley
said...
Then Senator Rand Paul said...
Then Senator Roger Marshall
said...
Then President Trump said...
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, Senator Mitch McConnell
said...
And finally,
Senator James Lankford said...
That's -- Everyone --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Everyone got their box checked.
Yeah.
Well, everyone's
talking about this.
Tucker Carlson is being
criticized by both parties
for saying that January 6th
was "mostly peaceful."
That's like if your main
takeaway from Woodstock '99
was that Limp Bizkit
played "Nookie."
You know what I'm saying?
Like...
Carlson also said that most of
the rioters were "sightseers."
But usually when sightseers
go to a museum,
they don't try to take a Picasso
home with them.
I'm just saying.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Meanwhile,
new legal documents reveal
that right before January 6th,
Tucker Carlson texted a coworker
about Trump
and said,
"I hate him passionately."
To be fair,
I feel like every friend group
has a second group text for that
one person they secretly hate.
"What was Jimmy talking about?"
[ Light laughter ]
Listen to this.
We all knew that
Kim Jong-un had a daughter,
but South Korean
intelligence officials said
now they believe Kim Jong-un
has three kids.
-Ooh.
-Yeah, he has three kids.
Eric, Ivanka, and Jong Jr.
-Ooh.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, this is exciting.
With the huge box-office success
of "Top Gun: Maverick,"
"Avatar: The Way of Water,"
"Cocaine Bear," and "Creed III,"
insiders believe that movies
are officially back.
-Yeah!
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And you can tell Netflix
may be a little jealous
based on some of the
notifications that have been
popping up lately.
Notifications like...
[ Laughter ]
Then I saw this one. It says...
Then there's...
And finally...
They're definitely upset.
-Wow.
-They are upset.
Some more entertainment news.
NBC has ordered
a car-makeover reality show
based on Mattel's
Hot Wheels toys.
Yep, a Hot Wheels makeover show.
People will say, "Whoa.
Look at the cool flames
on the side of that Tesla.
Wait. Those are real.
Hey! You okay?"
Speaking of Tesla,
the U.S. is investigating Tesla
over reports of steering wheels
falling off
while the cars are being driven.
[ Audience ohhs ]
I guess that's one way
to make a car driverless.
Uh...
Take the steering wheel off.
Well, get this. A viral TikTok
revealed that Chuck E. Cheese
still uses floppy disks
for its animatronic band.
[ Audience groans ]
Yeah.
Well, anyway, to prove that
they're still cool and modern,
Chuck E. Cheese updated
some of the band's music.
And it's a little surprising.
Take a look at this.
-♪ Mummy don't know
daddy's getting hot ♪
♪ At the body shop
doing something unholy ♪
I just thought that was --
Yeah, that was interesting.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I don't know.
Did you guys see this?
More than 300 people just got
sick on a Princess cruise ship.
Meanwhile, Carnival was like,
"300? That is so last year."
[ Laughter ]
Source of the outbreak
hasn't been confirmed,
but when the news broke,
the sushi buffet
grew legs and moonwalked
out of the room.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, I saw a new survey
that said the top reasons
guests would leave a hotel room
they already paid for are...
bed bugs, a bad smell,
and finding a camera.
[ Audience groans ]
Motel 6 heard it and was like,
"Hey! 3 for 3!
We got hotel bingo! Alright!
[ Laughter ]
Cool."
And, finally,
have you guys noticed
that when you start typing
something on Google,
it automatically tries to
complete the search for you?
Yeah, well, it autofills
what you're looking for,
but sometimes their suggestions
are a little off.
I'm gonna show you what I mean.
It's time for
"Google Autofails."
Here. Check this out.
-♪ Google Autofails, yeah ♪
-Here's an example
that I typed in.
I said,
"Which country should I..."
These three things pop up.
"...visit for Spring Break?"
"...check out in Europe?"
"...move to after the U.S.
bans TikTok?"
[ Laughter ]
These are autofills.
-Autofails!
Here's another one I typed in.
It said,
"Why did Tucker Carlson..."
"...get his own show?"
"...get the January 6th tapes?"
"...describe 'Creed III'
as 'mostly peaceful'?"
[ Laughter ]
Next up, I typed in,
"Are the contestants on
'The Masked Singer"..."
It said, "...really singing?"
"...getting paid?"
"...volunteers or prisoners?"
[ Laughter ]
Next up, I typed in,
"Can H&R Block..."
It said, "...do my taxes?"
"...answer my questions?"
"...take a shoebox full
of loose documents
and make sure
I don't go to prison?"
[ Laughter ]
"Look at this. Help me."
And finally, I typed in,
"I feel out of control when..."
It said, "...I party too much."
"...I have too much work."
"...the steering wheel
on my Tesla falls off."
That's it for
"Google Autofails."